♪♪♪
>> HONEY, WE JUST GOT AN ALERT.
THERE'S SOME WEIRD CHARGES ON
THE DISCOVER CARD.
I'LL CALL THEM.
>> GOOD LUCK.
YOU'LL JUST BE TALKING TO A
ROBOT.
>> NOPE, WITH THE DISCOVER CARD
YOU GET TO TALK TO A REAL PERSON
WHO'S JUST LIKE YOU.
[ PHONE RINGING ]
HELLO?
IS SOMEONE THERE?
>> DISCOVER-CARD.
>> HEY, GIRL.
THERE'S SOME WEIRD CHARGES ON MY
ACCOUNT.
I THINK SOMEONE STOLE MY
IDENTITY.
>> I CAN HELP YOU WITH THAT.
>> OH, GIRL ARE YOU SICK?
ANYWAY, IT LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE
USED MY CAR TO BUY A BUNCH OF
RED JUMP SUITS, MOTORCYCLE
GLOVES, HUNDREDS OF RABBITS AND
SOME GIANT SCISSORS.
>> THAT'S SO RANDOM.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I SAY RANDOM ALL THE TIME.
ARE YOU ME?
>> WHAT?
A LONG TIME --
>> SORRY, CAN WE SPEED THIS UP?
MY FAMILY AND I ARE ON VACATION.
>> WHEN YOU GO ON VACATION, I
SIT IN A CAVE.
>> OH, THAT SOUNDS BAD.
I WOULD I NOT SWITCH PLACES WITH
YOU.
>> BE CAREFUL.
>> HELLO?
BABE, I'M NOT GETTING ANYWHERE
WITH THIS WOMAN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I GOT THIS.
GIVE ME THE PHONE.
YEAH, IS THIS DISCOVER?
HEY, THAT'S WHY YOU HANDLE THE
MONEY.